Nadia Nadeem was born in Afghanistan at
the age of 11 her father a general in
the Afghan National Army was executed by
the Taliban
her mother fled the country with her
five daughters selling their possessions
to fund their escape
on forged passports they traveled by
Trump to Italy and went on to a refugee
camp in Denmark and it was there that
she discovered football after seeing a
group of children playing it over a
fence and despite not speaking any
English or Danish suggested to the coach
that she wanted to play and he let her
join in well Nadia went on to play for
the Danish national team over a hundred
times for her adopted Homeland
and last week Nadia was on air covering
the World Cup but her Joy at this career
high is a broadcaster was sadly
tarnished by the terrible news that her
mother had been killed in a road
accident let's have a look how the table
is after all that I'm afraid Nadia's had
to leave us at short notice despite
losing the person she called the most
important in her life Nadia returned to
work and was back on air within days
[Music]
and Nadia joins me now Nadia thank you
so much for joining me first my deepest
condolences to you on the loss of your
mother it was an awful thing to hear
about here at the World Cup we're all
aware of what had happened and you had
to leave very suddenly and then we found
out why your mother being killed him his
accident but it also made me go away and
research you and your life because I
didn't know much about you if I'm honest
and what I found was quite extraordinary
and I wanted to get you on the show just
to really talk about
so that's what's happened to you in the
last seven days but also to talk about
why your mother was so important to you
and this extraordinary Journey you went
on with her from Afghanistan to get you
to where you are today so thank you
first of all and my deepest condolences
as I say to you and all your family
you were commentating last week it was a
last Tuesday yeah and you suddenly get
told that your mother has died in this
awful accident yeah that for you must
have been just a given all you'd been
through together yeah a terrible moment
yeah definitely you know I think as you
said Tunisia versus Denmark sitting
there and I started receiving a lot of
messages from family no one was really
telling me what was happening everyone
was like have you heard are you on your
way and finally in second half I got to
I got a call from my cousin and he had
told me that my mom had passed away and
for the first 10 minutes I wasn't
believing it I was like I can't be my
mom was a healthy Woman and you know 57
years old
um
like I I couldn't really believe in
especially the way they told me it was
like an accident
um and yeah flew back home and yeah it
was the reality it's a definitely
heartbroken unexpected not only for me
but entire family and the the really sad
part of this was that she'd gone to the
gym early so that she could get back in
time to watch you commentating because
that was what she was so proud of and
you know that's just a Twist of faith
yeah yeah definitely I think yeah
one thing that I you I know for you know
in life for sure is that nothing's 100
and
everything can happen right away and
then as I said we did not expect it and
her dying that way is is hard uh
because I was you know expecting to live
and be with her for the next 20 years
um one of the closest persons in my life
I mean the closest person one of the
strongest women I've ever encountered my
life and not just because she was my mom
but because the hardships she's been
going through and how she raised us you
know five kids alone actually took us
from one continent to another
and yeah losing her life that way I
heard me but on the other hand it's you
know I have her in me and her you know
Spirit her fighting mentality and now
I'm gonna do everything my hands to make
her friends no the mere fact you come
back to the world cup says that I mean
that's exactly the kind of spirit that
your mother had that she would have
wanted you to show and I want to take
you back now to Afghanistan
first of all you're living there with
your parents and your Four Sisters I
think you have yeah and your father is
in the Afghan military he's a general I
think is that right
and he was murdered by the Taliban when
you were just 11 years old yeah what are
your memories of that awful time
uh I mean yeah 11 years old the Vivid
memories I remember everything it was a
very until that point you know I think
my life's been always very protective my
dad was General my mom was a school
teacher lecturer later on and we've
always been very protected but after
Taliban gained power
killed my dad because obviously he had a
very high position in the in the Army
and everything off of that it was just
like chaos
we were trying to survive for a very
long time trying to make it in the
country but it was hard you know five
girls and a mom went into hiding I think
yes quite a while yeah and then you went
to Pakistan you've got some stolen
passports and you eventually find
yourselves in Denmark I think you
thought you were going to England at one
stage yeah and a funny story huh
we have family in England and at that
point obviously we want to be reunited
with their family but Faith didn't want
us to end up in England for some reason
and honestly I don't really care because
we were together and we were in safety
and that's the point of the entire thing
and there's an amazing moment you're in
Denmark and you're in a uh like an
asylum Camp a refugee camp
and you look over a fence and you see
some kids playing football
and you've never played the game I don't
think until that point you don't speak
either English or Danish
but you're desperate to get involved and
eventually the coach who's teaching
these kids says come on then you can
join in yeah what was it about football
that you were drawn to
I mean there's so many things I'm drawn
you know to to the game uh I remember
one of the first time I saw a girl's
team play
uh the girls who were playing they
looked happy and they look free and me
coming from a country where I had to be
in hiding and always felt unsafe that
was something that attracted me and
you'd also been prevented from going to
school yes like by the Taliban yeah
correct so um I don't know it just the
game was speaking to me and I wanted to
be that person on the field and you know
it's one of those moments struck by
lightning and my eyes were widened up
and I was like I wanna I wanna be that
kid and um you know I have this I don't
know I always thought it was from my
dad's side this this fire inside of me
but I for sure know now it's from my
mom's side I do both right yeah I guess
so it's a combination
um yeah and it turns out you are
unbelievably good at football
in fact you go on to play for Denmark
over a hundred times you score on a
European Championship final you're a
brilliant player you're one of the great
female footballers there's ever been
and yet it was all really just
fortuitous the luck of the draw of life
that took you from Afghanistan to
Denmark and then this remarkable career
fate yeah I do believe in fate and I
think also one of that's one of the
reason I can sit here today after less
than seven or Six Days Seven Days my mom
passed away because I'm I'm an emotional
person but I'm very often irrational
thinking you know I think what's meant
to be it's meant to be and I try to find
a positive every situation I am in and I
think football gave me a life and you
know my background brought me to
football and then football gave me the
life I have today and and um yeah when I
want to take it and I want to do as much
as good possible most people would say
that's enough
drama
horror
challenges for one life but not you
you've decided to become a doctor
and you're now involved in in surgery in
repairing bodies effectively right yeah
actually graduate as a doctor this
January January 14th I haven't finished
you know becoming surgeon yet this is
something I'm going to qualify whenever
I'm done but yeah a doctor is a big
thing my mom my mom that was one of her
wishes you know one of our kids to be a
doctor and and now she has two doctors
and two nurses and her family and then
yeah and you've been around
reconstructive surgeons I know yeah and
you talked about how some of the skills
you need to be a very super confident
football player actually are quite
they're quite similar to the skills you
need to be a top surgeon yeah definitely
I think you have to be able to
uh work on the pressure the
responsibility I really like and also
feels like the adrenaline that you have
on the surgeries uh it's very similar to
scoring it's scary being in a surgical
room
with a real patient and trying to save
their life or playing a European
championship final
uh
Gary to be honest they're both very
equal how many languages do you speak
quite a lot how many
fully around nine which ones
so I speak
Danish English French
German Hindi Persian daddy Urdu I speak
Einstein of situation Norwegian because
they're quite similar to
to is there anything you can't do that
probably is quite a lot of things I
don't know yet but if I start focusing
on them I'm probably gonna learn them I
mean it's a remarkable story
and I'm again so sorry about the loss of
your mother because it's now so apparent
to me why she was such a pivotal person
in your life you know you made this
journey with her from Afghanistan to
Denmark without her I guess none of you
would have made it
you're 100 correct uh and I you know I
really feel she gave us
life twice once when she gave birth to
me and second time when she took me from
Afghanistan to Denmark to have a better
future brighter future
and yeah it's someone I'm gonna always
remember and I I want to remember the
gifts you know the happy memories I had
with her what kind of woman was your
name is hedima what kind of woman was
she
my mom was a very stubborn woman if she
once set her mind to something she'll go
for it and it didn't matter if the
entire world was against her she's very
intelligent and then
just like this little lady with so much
energy in her so much power and someone
who who people listen to and she touched
so many people's lives and even to a
funeral it was a Friday 9 30 and I we
just announced the day before because
I'm a Muslim and our religion you have
to bury you know as soon as possible and
there were like thousand people there
and then it just showed what kind of
human being she was someone who touched
people's hearts
do you feel like she's with you in
spirit yeah definitely
the reason I'm so calm
faith I believe she's a bad place
and what's meant to be to be and for me
to lay down and then you know cry my
eyes out for months and months I don't
think that's gonna fix anything she's
not gonna come back if that was the case
trust me I'll be the one doing that so
I'll try to you know take that energy
those emotions and put something that
that you know will remember her honor
her and hopefully for me you know
bring me food in life you're only 34
years old
and yet you've experienced so much in
your life
what's what's next for you do you think
I hope this drama in that way less
tragedy I hope that you know I can I can
grow into a person who can have an
impact not only on my life on people
around me but you know people who are in
need that's something that I'm
passionate about that's something my mom
was passionate about
um so yeah and I work hard for it
we're going to talk football uh tonight
obviously
um what do you make of the World Cup so
far who are your picks to perhaps Win It
honestly you've been enjoying the World
Cup you know watching the games at the
stadiums been great atmosphere for me
there's a couple of teams who've been
doing very well I think we can all uh
agree on that Brazil looks very sharp
the reason for me they're looking so
good and probably one of my favorites to
win this tournaments because they're so
balanced as a team they have great
Striker it's not one player they have
like you know
four or five that can decide games great
Midfield experience back and then two of
the best Premier League Keepers there is
right
and France before the World Cup I was
counting them because they're missing
you know the engine and and Pogba and
kante but actually with the two young
midfielders they've been doing very well
you know what when you've got killing
and Batman up front and he's playing
like he is I guess you can win anything
yeah that's that's fact well let's see
when the games are getting you know a
bit harder if he's gonna maintain a lot
of very excited American fans I mean
it's a massive moment for team us
because they've beaten Iran obviously a
very highly charged fixture that uh
historically a lot of tension building
up to it but America have gone through
to the last 16. who knows maybe England
America in the final
that's very optimistic I'm sorry to say
so but you know what this work have
shown that everything can happen if I
say to you will Saudi ever beat
Argentina you just said don't be
ridiculous that's true facts this is the
World Cup where Miracles are happening